i'm so excited to be here for meat week
i know
right finally all right what are we
making today palar
so today we're making a peppery steak
with an agridolce sauce now explain what
agri dolce is
okay so agua dolce is an italian
condiment basically
it's a little bit sweet a little bit
sour a lot of punch
it's a really nice compliment to the
take shall we get good let's do it let's
do it
so we're going to start with this new
york strip over here okay
for this recipe the reason why i love
the new york strip
is because it's tender like a filet and
it has the flavor
and fat just like a ribeye so the first
thing we're going gonna do
is season up the steak really really
well
i'm a really big proponent of seasoning
your meat in advance
um and then you park that for like an
hour and let it sit
okay we have some freshly crushed black
peppercorns
you're going to lay that on your plate
or on top and
you're going to press down to adhere
so we've seasoned off both sides and
meanwhile
you want your pan heating over medium to
medium-high
heat polar i've decided without question
i like the roll on
beautiful the pepper on the plate so
when your pan is nice and hot you're
going to add some oil
and right here actually we have a steak
that has
been searing so it's nice and hot time
to turn it over
yeah i like to look at that beautiful
so this recipe is gonna cook stove top
for six minutes but just make sure
you're doing essentially
the same amount of time on both sides
same amount of time on both sides and
we're gonna
finish this steak in the oven okay
basically
um one thing to look for when you're
going into the oven is definitely
use an oven thermometer um okay by the
way
i have a really searing burning question
i get intimidated with putting my pan
into the oven
because i'm always worried i'm going to
melt it but i know finishing a steak off
in an oven
is crucial tell me about pans pilar
i feel like i can help you with that one
i'm going to walk this over and come
right back
all right perfect roll the tape
so you want to sear a steak but aren't
sure which pan can go in the oven
here's how pilar does it her go-to's are
cast
iron carbon steel or stainless steel
skillets in
that order cast iron is built to last
super versatile
and gives you that just right crust
carbon steel is lighter than cast iron
and the most commonly used in
restaurants and stainless steel is
sturdy and reliable
but no matter which pan you pick keep
these safety tips in mind
use comfy pot holders have a trivet
ready to receive
and pilar leaves her mitt on the handle
as a visual reminder
that's it until we meet again okay
first of all you're just the prettiest
cutest human
planet let me show you some pretty cute
sauce so we're gonna make the agra dolce
sauce real quick
we're gonna dump everything in that's
two tablespoons of shallots
two tablespoon shallots all that roughly
chopped cranberries
wonderful and then that is my balsamic
over there
some water and then we're gonna do some
honey so all you have to do is basically
bring this to a boil
and then simmer it for four minutes
until it's
nice and thick so here we have the
balsamic that has been reduced a little
and the last little thing is off the
heat
we're going to pour in our mustard
all right so we actually on the side
drew have a steak beautiful steak that
has been resting
critical piece to cooking steak rest
your meat for at least
10 minutes what does cutting on the
grain mean because that also
throws so you're going to cut against
the grain so basically if you
stay kind of parallel to you and you're
going to cut this way and you can go as
thin
or as thick as you want beauty beauty
beautiful
oh my god so good i just want to eat it
all right so the last thing to do
is just spoon some of that beautiful
sauce on mm-hmm
oh this cuts well i guess
i'm sorry i don't i just eat
it is really really good this is the
perfect temperature whatever this is
so vffs i hope you're all meat lovers
or knitworks for fish too because you're
all getting a meter plus
smart meat thermometer i know
which is such a game changer and a
delicious craft meat
gift box from porter road
you guys are all getting that
um okay uh pilar i'm really excited
about this because this has a lot of
heart and soul for us
absolutely all right you're gonna be
here next monday
and we are kicking off something that i
have a lot of hope for
um it's cookbook club and we're gonna be
talking about
actually uh this book the essentials of
italian cooking
um by marcela hazan yep
and um tell everybody what we're going
to be making pilar
so uh next monday we're going to make be
making a beautiful pasta
a bucatini with a matriciana sauce
so you say it so much better i'm so
relieved i had to take that one
and if you guys want to join in with us
we would love it the recipe is on page
157 of this book
see i'm already dog-eared and ready to
go and what we want you to do is cook
with us
send us your pictures send us your video
let us know
what you like about the recipe and we
would love to
tag on social media drew's cookbook club
and we would love to post some of your
photos and videos and some might even be
featured on the broadcast
so let's do this this is a personal
dream
of mine and i couldn't do it alone i
could only do it with pilar
thank you looking forward to it so much
you know what it's really inspired by
for me pilar
was i am an avid cookbook collector we
cook in a kitchen together that is
floor-to-ceiling cookbooks everywhere
you turn as a cookbook
when the pandemic started and everybody
started making those sourdough loaves
i thought could my love of cookbooks
and everybody's desire to cook in
harmony to cook in community
to challenge themselves to express
themselves and feel a part of something
that's what inspired this idea yeah
thank you paulary love you for having me
[Music]